Disney released the second trailer for
its remake of the classic film The Lion
King in it we get a glimpse of the main
characters and we finally get to hear
some of them speak for the very first
time though the film is still
technically animated this version is a
more photorealistic take on the story
there are also lots of shots that mirror
the original animated film here is
everything you might have missed the
trailer opens with young Simba and Nala
walking through the elephant graveyard
this is the wasteland beyond the borders
of the pride land where Simba is told
not to go English never go there soon
it's also the home of the three honey no
villains
Shenzi Banzai and edy we hear Skaar
voiced by Truitt elegy ofor say life's
not fair a classic line from the film in
which he's talking to a mouse that he's
about to eat live not bad well the scar
in the new film seems to have the same
scar over his left eye he has a piece of
flesh missing from his right ear he also
doesn't have the green eyes from the
cartoon which makes sense
since the movie is going for a more
realistic look next we see a shot
straight out of the original film with
the birds flying over the water of the
pride lands and Simba on top of the
cliff with his father Mufasa
[Music]
James Earl Jones reprises his role as
the voice in the remake a true king such
as the what he could do the trailer also
gives us our first look at a zoo the
red-billed hornbill voiced by comedian
John Oliver
he's the majordomo or chief steward to
King Mufasa what am I going to do with
him he'd make it very handsome thread
rug we also see a pretty close
shot-for-shot version of the scene just
after the elephant graveyard in which
Mufasa and Zazu are leading Simba and
Nala back home in shame there's even a
recreation of the iconic moment when
young Simba puts his paw in his father's
print we also see the wildebeest
stampede orchestrated by scar which
results in the death of Mufasa and scar
telling Simba run away Simba two more
memorable characters we get a first look
at in the new trailer are the meerkat
Timon and warthog Pumbaa voiced by Billy
Eichner and Seth Rogen we see them
walking with Simba in an almost exact
recreation of the original scene a
time-lapse of Simba growing older during
Hakuna Matata
while the trailer shows Simba eyeing a
Beatle in the original Pumbaa is the one
chasing the bug after Simba and Nala
finally reunite they are seen drinking
water together which you might remember
during the song can you feel the love
tonight we see almost the exact same
scene in the new trailer the adult
versions of these characters will be
voiced by donald glover and beyonce
knowles carter meanwhile Rafiki is
painting a red mane around Simba's image
in the original film he does this when
he realizes Simba is still alive and is
now matured after scar dies and Simba
reclaims his rightful spot on the throne
we see him walk up the cliff and roar in
the pouring rain
another scene nearly identical to the
original the trailer basically gives us
a taste of what we can expect from start
to finish well we don't hear any of the
famous musical numbers there's a slight
tease at the end we hear a snippet of
Timon and Pumbaa singing in the jungle
just as they did in the original we can
likely expect to see more and hear more
of the music from the film in the days
to come ahead of the movie's release in
July 2019